انهيار سد نوفا كخوفكا جنوبي اوكرانيا هو
احد اكبر الكوارث البيئيه في اوروبا منذ
عقود قرن باكملها دمرت وغمرت الاراضي
الزراعيه وحرم الالاف من الناس من الماء
والكهرباء
منذ وقوع الكارثه ولعبه تبادل التهم
متواصله بين موسكو
روسيا القت باللوم على اوكرانيا ووصفت
الكارثه بانها عمل تخريبي هدفه حرمان شبه
جزيره القرن التي ضمتها روسيا اليها عام
2014 من المياه بينما سارعت اوكرانيا الى
اتهام روسيا
هذه ليست كارثه طبيعيه او مظهرا من مظاهر
ازمه المناخ بل هي كارثه بوتين
المتسبب بدمار السد ما يزال مجهولا ففيما
تدعي اوكرانيا ان لديها ادله تثبت ان
روسيا فجرته عمدا انطلاقا من مكالمه
هاتفيه بين عسكريين روسيين اثنين تم
تسريبها من قبل جهاز الامن الاوكراني وهي
مكالمه يعترف فيها العسكريان الروسيان بان
مجموعه مواليه لروسيا كانت وراء الهجوم
قوه
[موسيقى]
في هذا الحدث هو ان لدى روسيا سببا مقنعا
للقيام بهدم السد لمنع القوات الاوكرانيه
من التقدم مبرر اخر للكرملين وهو ان الضعف
الهيكلي وضغط المياه هم اللذان تسببت في
انهيار الجدار الخزان
وفي اخر المواقف حمل الاتحاد الاوروبي
روسيا مسؤوليه تفجير السد كون ان
المتفجرات زرعت في التوربينات التي تقع
تحت سيطره الجانب الروسي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات